more than five years ago islamists
attacked the paris offices of the
satirical magazine
charlie hebdo and a jewish supermarket
they murdered 17 people before being
shot dead by police
they had accomplices who escaped and
their trial has now begun
the magazine was targeted because it
published cartoons of the prophet
muhammed
we'll have an update soon from paris but
first
dw's lisa lewis met the widow of one of
those killed
maurice wolinski is still traumatized
five years ago her husband george was
killed in the islamist attack on charlie
hebdo
he was a cartoonist at the magazine and
the love of her life
[Music]
my life was turned upside down it's his
absence
the absence of his gaze that accompanied
me for 47 years
this absence has caused me to fall ill
with cancer
and i have regular nightmares in some of
them
i become my husband and live through his
last moments
facing the kalashnikov
maris is one of the plaintiffs in the
court case
she's hoping the hearings will provide
her with some answers
i need to understand as best as i can
what was in the mind of his assassin
he
any additional information could help me
get closer to what my husband went
through
the moment he got killed
attack put france on high alert the
terrorists were on the run for days
millions of people then took part in a
huge demonstration of unity
in the face of this attack on press
freedom the slogan
went global
but since the attack on charlie hebdo's
newsroom
behind me here defending the freedom of
the press in france has become more
difficult
especially with the rise of populist
politics
and an increasing distrust of the
traditional media
charlie abdul has continued to operate
from a secret location
the magazine still regularly receives
threats
its editor-in-chief says the internet
has made things worse
nowadays when people read critical
comments on social media
they immediately take them personally
they often threaten us in a very violent
way
satire and press cartoons are supposed
to upset people
and be thought provoking that cartoon
culture is increasingly
getting lost
maurice wolenski is trying to maintain
her husband's legacy in her own way
jerrod i am pursuing one of his projects
a european house of satirical and press
cartoons
this is how i continue his fight for
press freedom
she will also keep publishing her
husband's cartoons
so that his spirit lives on
and let's go now to the courtroom in
paris where our correspondent lisa lewis
is covering the trial
for us lisa this trial bringing up
painful memories in france for so many
as we've just seen there in that report
what are people saying now five years
later
well absolutely this trial is indeed
very important for many people here
first of all obviously the survivors and
the families of
the victims they have to they're looking
for answers they're looking
to understand what really happened and
that might help them
to live a bit in a bit more easy way
without paying their heart to face they
have been facing
since january 2015 but this trial is
also crucial for france as
a country it's a historical trial and as
a one lawyer
said this morning it's the democratic
answer to a barbaric
act so france is trying to understand
what really happened
there what went wrong what could be done
better better in the future to prevent
such
horrible attacks from happening and this
is also
a historical trial as to the fact that
it's been
it's being recorded and will be archived
that's very rare
in french judicial history with the goal
there of
prevention that you've mentioned uh we
have to mention that that charlie hebdo
is still
facing threats are writers artists
journalists are they still at risk if
they criticize islam in today's france
well that's at least what members of the
charlie hebdo newsroom have been telling
me they've been saying you know we feel
that
journalists in france are self-censoring
that they feel they shouldn't
aggress or shouldn't insult anybody for
fear
of reprisals one recent poll also showed
that more than 50 percent of those
questioned
thought that there shouldn't be a
journalist shouldn't express any
blessing you shouldn't insult
any religion however the charles d'or
news team
obviously obviously says that's what we
do we insult everybody and we have the
right
to love about everything and everybody
what do french citizens make of what's
going on right now with this trial
lisa i mean is this is this helping to
unify the country
that's obviously the hope here you know
when you look back at uh to trend to
january 2015
as i said in my report lots of people
came together to show
unity in the face of this horrible
attack on press freedom and many you
here are hoping
that this trial might again bring people
together
because they shouldn't forget that
they're facing this common enemy of of
violence against this freedom however
there are
other fractures in french society when
you look back at the yellow west
movement you know these demonstrations
that went on
for over a year and showed that showed
that there was
this uh rift between you know the
countryside
and the city here in france and then
many people feel left
behind by those who earn more
and and and those people who feel left
behind certainly won't feel better
because of this trial
but they might stand together for a
moment just to remember that they are
one nation and should really face uh
show unity in face of such an attack
with the view from paris dw's lisa lewis
as this trial begins today a number of
alleged accomplices
facing justice for their role in the
charlie hebdo
massacre thanks for your reporting lisa
you